this morning the house begins another
historic day of Deadlock over choosing a
speaker Republican Kevin McCarthy has
failed to secure the votes he needs
after 11 ballots the process hasn't gone
this far in more than 150 years Robert
Costa joins us from Capitol Hill Bob
good morning good morning Nate late last
night some of these conservative
holdouts felt they were making progress
a deal coming together with McCarthy
giving them more power on key committees
on fiscal policy and on floor rules but
many McCarthy critics remain firm knows
a speaker has not been elected for the
11th time this week Congressman Kevin
McCarthy lost his bid to become house
Speaker I think we've got a little
movement so we'll see so if this takes a
little longer and it doesn't meet your
deadline that's okay because it's not
it's not how you start it's how you
finish many republican holdouts have
expressed individual grievances with
McCarthy making this more of a personal
not ideological Showdown it is not
happening and as it's been said
we need to get to a point where we start
evaluating what life after Kevin
McCarthy looks like Florida's Matt Gates
going as far as nominating the former
president I nominate president Trump
because we must make our country great
again and he can start by making the
House of Representatives great again
some GOP lawmakers are raising concerns
about whether the concessions McCarthy
is making to win votes may come at too
high a price if things went too far and
completely changed in the way Congress
runs then that might be a bridge too far
and so that's been the concern of a lot
of members that you know you you have to
be careful in the deals that are being
made While others argue they won't be
held hostage by the group opposey
McCarthy and are standing by him I will
never vote for anyone that those 20 want
me to vote for
don't care if they're my best friend
won't vote for them this is this is not
about McCarthy anymore this is about
principle this is about the institution
from McCarthy allies the calculus right
now behind the scenes is that he's going
to have to deal with these conservative
critics all year might as well bring
them inside the tent right now give them
a seat at the table and hope that
eventually they turn their eye or their
frustration away from him and toward the
Biden White House Adriana
Bob thank you